but who are the ones attacking the
shared vision of what makes the country
who are the ones attacking the shared
values and that's why again going back
to your point and i and i truly mean
this
the long run i like the fact that you
want to be a we i want to be a wee
wouldn't that be great when i look at
our
we institutions you take something as
simple as
this is a minute and a half of your time
that we're gonna say the darn national
anthem and you sing it and you're gonna
be quiet
and and for this minute and a half
whether you like it don't like it you
think it's stupid this minute and a half
is not your minute it is it's the
national anthems minute and we're all
gonna shut the hell up just like at your
wedding when someone was when you were
doing your vows if i stood up and was
like you know i want to make a comment
right now people will be like whoa whoa
whoa this is jack and tonya's wedding
this is why we didn't invite anybody
exactly almost this is not your time the
national anthem is not your this belongs
to the country shut the hell up you know
i want to protest you got the whole
world to protest but this belongs to the
shared values of the country but you
can't have it what do you do now it has
to now it's destroyed this flag you
can't have it this image can't have it
there are no more shared images because
we are told and and let me know
let me throw this out there for grabs to
kind of put put a pin on that is what
and what you were saying earlier ian
what do you think would happen if you
went to afghanistan right now and tried
to set a taliban flag on fire
you'd probably get gundam what do you
think would happen if you went out there
and you saw you know a a you know a
taliban
uh you know sure council meeting and you
walked up and started protesting what do
you think what happened
what do you think would happen if when
the after the taliban took over you took
the afghan national flag and started
carrying it through the streets oh wait
that did happen that already people were
brutally beaten what happens when you
when you when you knock down a pride
flag
the hate police in new york i think it's
in queens are the hate police is out
because it's on camera someone knocked
down a pride flag
we have two you're not allowed to do
that we have sporting events doing two
national anthems now
they why not three
i'm not into the symbolism thing like if
if xi jinping commanded us to sing the
national anthem it wouldn't be he will
american pride oh he would like not the
americans don't step on my freedom oh
it'll it'll be
like if xi jinping makes me say i love
america it doesn't mean i really love
america no one's asking you to say you
love america they are asking for this
one particular moment this thing does
not belong to you and it is humbling for
all of us and the collective values of
this country to say you know what that's
not mine just like those vows that
moment your speech you know what it's
it's ian's birthday ding ding ding and
ian wants to no no no no i'm going to
start and this is also this is my what
this is one moment in time that does not
belong to any individual
but no individual can use serpent ian
there's got to be something that unites
a community so that when it comes to
conflict they say we may disagree on x y
and z but because of the overarching
umbrella we are here for each other
america used to be they talk about
diversity the great melting pot but
american culture and values always
superseded so when people talk about
multiculturalism there's two definitions
the left definition well i should say
the the original view of
multiculturalism was you can come and
have chinatown you can have ukrainian
village little italy little russia
whatever but you followed the rules and
the overarching culture of america and
you know what people liked that that's
why they wanted to be here but maybe
they spoke ukrainian and wanted to live
by their relatives but they still were
free speech they still were second
amendment they still wanted to you know
live in this great country what started
happening now is that multiculturalism
multiculturalism has come to mean
something different that there are
pockets that exist outside of americans
values and cultures when those start
growing a completely
separate moral framework there is
nothing uniting two groups you end up
with two national anthems within the
same space and i'll tell you this
two objects cannot occupy the same space
so when you have people who are under an
umbrella all saying okay you know i like
skateboarding you like bmx and he likes
snowboarding but we're all americans we
believe in free speech and we like
watching you know michael jackson music
videos or something that unites us we
don't have that anymore now you have
people who say all of your movies are
racist and bad and you're not allowed to
like them anymore we're going to sing a
different national anthem okay you have
a completely different worldview a
completely different moral framework and
these things struggle to coexist with
each other that's the that's that's the
thing about the national anthem i don't
think it's necessarily that we like
force people to undergo it but it's it's
more a sign that when we come to a point
where we cannot agree the national
anthem is something that we'll listen to
and like and we're proud of that half
the people are like play a different one
now in one arena people are are fighting
a symbolic or ideological war when they
say they're gonna do two national
anthems well it's also you know i mean
you think of it right
any sporting event is already two
teams and two groups of fans that are
there in opposition right they're there
to
i want to defeat you you want to defeat
me look i'm from philadelphia so you
know whenever you know whenever we were
playing you know where the giants were
in town you know it it got pretty rough
like we literally had a i almost was
attacked at a sports game yeah we
literally involved more screaming for
the browns yeah exactly but yeah but
philly fans are the most awful people
philly eagles fans no offense to
philadelphia but we're actually quite
proud of it we're actually quite proud
of
you
yeah no we would have fans we have we
had an actual trial we had an actual
trial court that would sit at the
stadium right because there were so many
fights that broke out that they didn't
even want to have to bring somebody up
uptown they would just they brought the
judge to the stadium they called it
eagles cork right and i've i've seen
but anyway but but to my point right
even in the city of philadelphia
for that moment
when you've got two sides that want to
go after each other for that moment you
put that crap aside and you say what you
know what we're all americans
those two guys who would fight at the at
you know that game in philadelphia they
beat it up later they no no they'll
fight each other but if you went up and
said something like if you went to guy a
and said do you like america he'd be of
course sky be like america of course
we're fighting over him spilling my beer
right exactly now you go into these well
i don't know how much the fans actually
care about this stuff but now you'll
actually have uh with the olympics for
uh for instance in the soccer and the
kneeling and everything you'll have some
people being like america is evil and
racist the other person would be like i
like america they don't even think it
was was it daily caller or campus reform
they went to georgetown and they were
asking about this they're asking about
the olympic team and they and they went
around interviewing students like man on
the street interviews and they couldn't
find now of course you know there's
editing and selection bias et cetera but
they went through student after student
and they couldn't they every single one
was getting up there saying i just don't
know how i can root for this team i can
root for individual you know i can root
for some mobiles i can root for you know
various um
different athletes that are in this but
for the united states no i couldn't and
if you noticed that's how they marketed
the olympic team this year and what
annoys me about that is that then those
athletes though megapino they flew over
on american tax dollars right like their
team is funded by the taxpayers so so
they will take all of the good that
comes with it but then for just that you
don't have to say megan repino you love
america but for that one moment as a
courtesy to all of us who pay our damn
taxes and allow this to happen for you
shut your damn pie hole and she couldn't
do that because that moment is not
our moment it's still my moment imagine
when megan repino kicked a goal
all the fans were like you know what you
don't get to celebrate we're going to do
this and she'd be like wait a second
this is my moment right imagine if you
scored a touchdown and and the fans were
like you don't get to celebrate that we
all need to take a knee and protest
what's happening in bangladesh
the wide receiver would be like what the
hell i just scored a touchdown this is
my moment no it's not megan repino if
you want to show your pro your true
protest moment every time you scored a
goal you should have taken a knee right
but when she scored a goal she won her
freaking applause about her she wanted
to be congratulated
let me say one name tamyra mensah stock
amazing who's that
why
has she been disappeared from the entire
narrative the entire conversation right
i say the name of people like tomorrow
meant to stock i don't know who to where
is that why isn't that name on
everybody's
right front of mind why isn't that front
of mind why didn't she define the
narrative because she defied the
narrative and it was some guy on twitter
who went and found her speech afterwards
she was the wrestler wrestler she was
the wrestler and she won the gold and
they went to her and she had the flag
draped over her shoulders and when they
asked her they said how do you feel
about that that flag and she said i love
the united states of america i love
living there i love representing this
country it's the most happiest moment of
my entire life just to be here and you
could see the patriotism they wrote her
out of it was it was it forest who said
that uh it might have been for us maybe
it was you that we're actually in this
country having a debate as to whether
this country should even exist as far as
yeah yeah yeah last week yeah that's
that's that's literally where we are
right now as a country right and so and
and just to to like kind of
encapsulate all of this that we're
talking about from january 6 to uh the
decline of nationalism and patriotism
it's
this is all for show by the way right
what's going on on an economic level in
this country
is far beyond anything that we've seen
before the divergence of when you talk
about class when you talk about
a new aristocracy all of that's going on
behind the scenes and yet they throw all
these things at you in the foreground to
make you forget about it but when you go
back and you actually look at things
that have happened in just the past 10
years or you know we're talking about
the fall you know the fall of kabul the
end of afghanistan right you know if you
could start with 911 and then just go
through everything that's happened in
the past 20 years and then you know you
combine that with the rest of the 20th
century right and i know you guys were
talking about that last night
that you really realize there's been a
whole lot that's going on that actually
matters that we are being distracted
about that we are being told you know oh
they want you fighting you know amongst
yourselves over the different national
anthems because they know what they're
doing behind the scenes they're robbing
you blind they are putting you in a po
and they are putting you into perpetual
poverty they are putting you to pit they
want you to be perpetual consumers and
serfs and everything else and that's why
the where it comes the abandoning
thousands of americans in in kabul is
unsurprising as tragic as it is it's
totally unsurprising because american
government has abandoned its people for
like you said 20 years
they look at them as deplorable we
abandoned people in toledo and we sent
all their jobs to china and mexico we
and we give them fentanyl by the way
we've abandoned people in in rural
america we've a bit the western
western maryland we talk about the
divides of the rich and the poor and the
haves and the have-nots and who's making
that capitalism no it's government
policy right we've abandoned people to
live in the inner cities and we look at
what we've done with them we've given
them the worst
literally the worst education in the
developed world and only though you're
going to get there we want to talk about
maybe a
a rough or a corrupt police force we've
given them that we've given them crime
and we've given them no education an
opportunity to escape in rural america
we've given them as lousy schools with
no jobs and no opportunities and tons of
fentanyl you know if fentanyl crossed
the border and it was killing rich white
liberal girls in manhattan it would have
been stopped like that but it's killing
poor rednecks and no one gives a damn
but not just rednecks so where you
showed me
in alaska alaska so my point is we
abandoned people in afghanistan american
government has abandoned people for for
years now thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time